so I'm fascinated by squatting not the
position the real estate move
the vagrant sees an empty home breaks in
makes it their own they live in your
house and you pay the bills there
they have rights to do this they call
them squatters rights and don't call the
cops because they won't help that's what
happened to our friend darthula in
Chicago
no they can't do anything about it when
I first went over there and you could
see the window was broken they broke in
they changed the locks my mother's
furniture and her personal belongings
are still on the property when I asked
them to remove him for breaking and
entering he told he told us that he's a
professional squatter and he knows his
rights so if you can't do anything and a
judge takes forever to hear your case
sometimes you need to take matters into
your own hands and that's what this
handyman did Flash Shelton Flash's mom's
home was vacant so a squatter moved in
she brought in all of her stuff so flash
found out and he sticked the house out
got there real early in the morning
waited until the squatter left and he
swooped in put some cameras up and when
the squatter came back he confronted her
watch
because I haven't been able to do
anything with this house for months
because every time they come over here
they tell me that there's people here
and if there's Furniture in the house
so and who's telling you that the
realtors that there's people here
because yeah so neighbors tell me that
they see people coming in and the lights
on someone went in and turned on the
power because their power was off to the
house some other people like young and
old and some uh a mixture between female
and males coming into the house at night
and the lights are on at night well that
would not be their neighbors their
neighbors there that would never be us
and those are the ones that have been
calling me telling so flash gave the
squatter an ultimatum if she didn't move
out or stuff he would
it all has to be out before I leave I've
got guys scheduled to come take the
stuff out later today so either you take
it out or I have to take it out and
put it out on the driveway until it gets
picked up
this is how it's done people founder of
the United handyman Association flash
Shelton joins me now flash that was a
smooth move she lied to your face though
did she at least admit maybe she was
caught cold
first of all Jesse I just want to say
thank you for having me on and you know
she she did she did apologize on the
video good and uh and she tried to say
that it wasn't her that they weren't in
the house but that her furniture was
accidentally delivered
accidentally delivered to the wrong
house and then she just happened to be
sitting on the furniture that was
accidentally delivered to a house that
wasn't hers
and she just happened to be pulling out
of the driveway in the morning when I
was scoping out the house
people that have a squatter situation
what if the person had never left the
house and you just stayed there staked
out all day what's the next move
well I mean I I you know obviously I
didn't know like who was in the house at
the time so I I probably would have you
know just kind of staked out the house
to see what type of individuals were
going in and then make a determination
if I needed to just enter the house
anyway I knew that the back door was
broken in preemptively I wrote up a
lease and had my mom basically make me
the legal tenant got it notarized I had
current utility bills with me in my name
I had keys to the house and at that
point I would have entered the house and
if the squatter can take a home I can
take a home if I enter the house they
can't kick me out just as much but with
having a lease and keys and utility
bills at that point you know if they
call the police the police would tell
them the same thing if I call the police
I can say hey I have an intruder in my
house and they've broken the back door
giving them that information they chose
to take the safe way out the easy way
out and move all their stuff out you are
so smart you had it all covered Nothing
Gets By flash is that your real name or
is that a nickname
flash you know since I was a little kid
so it's the only name I've gone by I
love it flash thank you so much you give
us all hope
and thanks I just want to yeah go ahead
no please finish
yeah I just want to say that you know I
appreciate all the the love and support
that I'm getting but I just hope that
you know that the outdated squatter laws
get some attention too so that maybe I
can help change them all right well
maybe Lindsey Graham can rewrite some of
those laws for us I know he's he's going
to be a little busy but
he's on a roll thank you very much Flash
thank you hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now